Listen up, people.
I am here, and I wanna help.
This is our planet.
Can I get a hurrah?
What am I, invisible?
Doesn't anybody care?
Listen to me!
I want one with relish.
And I want mine with mustard.
I want you to stop this insanity.
What do you think you're doing?
I'm trying to make a living here.
And the planet is dying!
Listen, I can't get a pulse.
What are you talking about?
There are 50,000 hot dog cows in Kansas alone.
So?
So? When those cows break wind, not only is it stinky,...
...but it's cutting a hole in the ozone.
Think of those hot dogs as one cubic foot of cow gas.
Bon appétit.
That's it.
See, we can make a difference.
I'll make a difference in your face if you don't get out of here.
Oh, the truth hurts doesn't it, Captain Carnivore?